sa voiture prend feu tu dois sortir
frustré
aniane
c'est vrai qu'il ya quelque chose chez
veulent alors tu ne crois pas en la
magie j'y croyais pas jusqu'à ce que je
te rencontre
je
envie ne ratez pas les kits solaires la
première depuis 50 ans avant on disait
que de grandes forces affrontés pendant
les éclipses lunaires cherchant à
protéger le monde
et l'autre à le détruire
qu'est ce qu'il ya qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
j'ai mené mon enquête il ya 50 ans un
professeur d'université a décrié mais
vision je dois leur trouver
tania je sais que tu as peur de moi
vous cherchez à la vérité
l'éclipsé a réveillé en elle pense
pouvoir mais désormais ce qui pose les
yeux sur elle
et leur plus grande peur
puissante force vont chercher à s'en
emparer
faire pour la sauver il y à une solution
mais acceptera tu d'en payer
[Musique]
notre sera tous des bandes vous salle
l'amour est la clé
[Musique]